e
e e
okay folks we're ready to go ahead with
our exec sessions today uh we have five
bills on the docket 773
739 563 675 and
115 what the process is going to be for
today we're going to start with 563 this
is a bill that does uh relative to the
adequate education grant amounts for
pupil receiving special education
services then work to 7:39 then to 7 73
just going in reverse order to the top
then we're going to break for lunch and
we're going to come back and deal the
other two bills following launch 675 and
1:15 we are still waiting on some
amending language for uh one of these
bills so uh we're going to start out
with
563 uh so I'm going to open up the
executive session on 563 right now and
I'm going to hand the gavel off
to representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman so on HB 563 I
recognize representative laad for a
motion thank you very much
representative spsb I would like to
recommend OTP on
563 OTP is there a second I'll second
that seconded by representative
luno uh discussion on your motion or
would you like to make yes I will go
straight to a second motion here I'd
like to do
otpa or an amendment off of this
amendment it's
06508 so the motion is on Amendment
06508 second by representative
luno and uh please address your
Amendment thank you very much we
recognize and understand that
revenues and expenditures now are not
really working together uh our Revenue
picture is is not as as bright as we'd
like to see it but we also recognize
that the adequacy formula which we have
um needs some help and so what we're
doing recognizing where we are during
the first year FY
26 the formula will remain the same as
it is right
now so going from left to right for the
base cost it's projected based upon the
2%
increase uh that we normally get per
statute and the differentiate Aid
components will remain the same with the
same 2%
increase the extraordinary needs Grant
which is on the right hand side which is
used to support those communities with
equal valuation property valuations uh
with the denominator being the number of
uh free and reduced students uh that
will remain the
same so this is basically what the the
bill the amendment addresses for FY 26
for FY
27 it is
different we are recommending that again
you have that
increase in cost for that based upon the
2% and the base cost will jump to
$435 per
pupil
the amount for the fnr free and reduced
meal plan will jump to
$2,441 per
pupil the amount for English language
learner differentiated jump to
$849 and and the amount for uh
addressing the issue of Ed special
education uh differentiated Aid this is
not the catastrophic Aid this is special
education Aid will jump from the 2100 up
to
$3,140 and I'd like to speak to that
just for a
second the the committee in our
discussions and our research has looked
at and recognized that all IEPs are not
the
same and there's 13 IEP
categories and and we've looked at those
categories and tried to figure out and
get information that is pretty much not
available to us from the department at
this time but how do we understand that
for example the to provide uh services
in the area of autism is going to be
more costly than that of a student
that's uh in another IEP category or and
there's 13 of them as I've mentioned so
what we did is we went and we've looked
at case loads that are recommended by
national organizations and come as close
as we can and developed a formula based
upon case loads to provide that service
for that
IEP the number of students in the state
that have that
identifying case load or IEP
disability and figured out the number of
teachers that are necessary to provide
services let's say in the first category
which is
autism we recognize that the cost of
providing service for a student with
that type of ser all students in the
state is over $20 million 20.8 million
dollar whereas when we went down and
looked at some of the other areas uh
like hearing impaired yes but there's
only a few students in state so that
cost is only
$42,000 when we added all these up we
came to a cost to provide special
education in the area of I the
differentiated Aid that cost
approximately $28 million more than what
we've been previously allocating in our
budget it jumped up close to $98
million and and the current expenditures
in that area are $68.7 million so we're
jumping roughly by that 28 million to
support that those services in uh FY 27
also we've looked at the right hand side
of the formula and recognized that the
extraordinary needs Grant deals with the
property valuations we are also wanting
to look at something more specific that
incorporates what we had in our law back
in 2011 fiscal capacity disparity Aid
and that is now injected into this
formula here and with
that we've have spreadsheets out there
available where you can see how that
will come out in terms of the various
communities and so Mr chair uh I believe
those uh spreadsheet has been handed out
uh and are available um at this point in
time I have nothing further to at this
time to to add to the
conversation okay
discussion on the amendment remains open
anybody El yes representative luno sure
thank you very much Mr chair so um so I
think this this the amendment certainly
moves moves things in the right
direction I think it it um it recognizes
the um the um um The increased costs
associated with with special education
certainly not to the extent that school
districts um recognize them themselves
but uh but by increasing the
differentiated Aid by by um um uh more
over
$1,000 U for the U for the special
education uh ADM I think that's very um
very significant uh also the um
introduction of fiscal capacity
disparity Aid as its own separate unique
uh characterist or U uh Grant is uh is
really important because it uh it does
doesn't conflate U two different things
like the extraordinary needs Grant does
uh access to resources and number of of
um of students coming from low-income
backgrounds it treats them as separate
uh yes as separate factors so I think
that's um that's that's very important I
also think um going through this
exercise certainly shows because it's a
little bit different than what we talked
about earlier last week um about bre up
the extraordinary needs Grant but
because the extraordinary needs Grant
came in along with a hold harmless in an
effort to replace
stabilization uh there's there's
certainly a a complexity to um uh to
that uh to that Grant and I hope that's
something this committee will uh will
continue to um uh to look at but uh but
I do support the amendment I do think it
moves Us in the right direction I hope
the committee sees that too okay thank
you for your comments uh representative
Ames thank you I I too will be
supporting this amendment um and uh see
it as uh a good faith effort
to respond to the degree that we can
respond in the current circumstances
to um a school
funding system that needs a lot more
work uh so this is a small step I
support it it will be helpful to many
communities mostly in a small way but
maybe in a big way if you look locally
at what's
coming um so it's to the good for most
communities and um let's understand that
there's a lot more work to be done thank
you further comments
representative fellas um yes can we have
U some kind of an explanation about the
at the top of the spreadsheet the
description it has this uh cap of
3,750 can somebody please explain that
I'm sorry you're not quite hearing
you so at the top of the spreadsheet
that's been handed out with the um award
per town There's um something
about um let's see the fiscal capacity
disparity
being not more than
3,700 per
pupil and
municipalities I don't know I'm can you
just explain that it says municipalities
with 5,000 or more
ADM and no more then it's supposed to be
no more than
3,750 dollar per pupil can you just
explain that whole part of it uh yes I
think we can
uh I'd just like to preface what I'm
about to say I certainly want to be on
the record as uh uh saying that the
reinstatement of fiscal capacity
disparity Aid through this bill as
amended
is in my estimation a
critical uh element for Property Port
Towns which I have the honor of
representing and uh it it will help
about 40 Target towns whose equalized
valuation per population is at the
lowest end of the
spectrum so to do that um there are a
couple of
limitations okay and the limitation of
Municipal ities with 5,000 plus
admr uh has to do with the skewed way in
which the extraordinary needs Grant
shifted an extraordinarily large amount
of money towards NASA and Manchester two
years ago and it partially corrects that
uh the only municipality that
actually uh would receive less under
this formula is
Manchester and I would characterize that
as a a dialing back uh of an excessive
swing of the pendulum two years ago um I
would also note that even as to
Manchester if you take their uh their
current uh uh appropriation and and the
allowance for 26 that doesn't change and
then consider that this doesn't take
effect till 27 they've got two years
heads up and it works out to about 6
million a year so I don't know if that
fully answers your question
representative fellows but the idea was
to to take a portion of the money that
has previously been dedicated to
extraordinary needs and and reassign it
along another parameter that's been more
or less ignored in our law for the last
14 years since 2011 so so one of my
concerns is we have I haven't even seen
what the formula is for doing that that
fiscal capacity disparity Aid if you
look in the bill
uh in the amendment well well I mean I
can read the words but pardon I can read
the words but we can't even see we don't
have an opportunity here to even see
Which towns are being affected by that
and to what
extent yeah what is it that you're
asking for I'm asking to see oh first of
all I want to say I understand the
special ed the justification for
increasing the special ed per pupil by
100 basically $100 per student a special
ed is being increased by
$1,041 per student 800 of which is uh an
adjustment we're making according to the
approach that representative lad
described and uh and then the other
portion being the cost of living
adjustment okay so that that part I
understand so it I'm focusing on the um
fiscal capacity disparity Aid and I
would like to
see how it impacts each
Town it doesn't I don't see that factor
and how it impacts each
town in accordance with the formula
which you'll see within this
amendment the formula go it it spreads
out the maximum Grant would be
$1,250 on the fiscal capacity of which
when you looking at your valuations per
pupil it goes in a range from $1 million
to $1.6 million per pupil so those 40
communities which are in that range are
going to receive funding from the fiscal
capacity disparity Aid
um
that the swing towards using that we had
basically for the extraordinary needs
Grant a limited amount of money $184
million roughly
to separate and place over and help some
of these property poor towns which we
have not been able to successfully do in
the past and I'm not advocating that
we're successfully doing it now but we
are putting together a formula which
directs money to those communities and
recognizes the need that's exist in
property poor communities so there's 40
communities which will benefit from the
shift of some of that money which is
within that $184
million so representative fellas the
spreadsheet that we have been given
allows you to look at any given town and
see what the change is right um I'm not
sure if you're asking for us to create a
new spreadsheet that would uh sort them
in some different way so this is mixed
in with the special ed increase
also so what I wanted to do was isolate
the fiscal disparity and see how that
the the monies are just coming from that
extraordinary needs Grant area and the
the uh Revenue that's necessary that
additional $28 million which is
necessary to support differentiate Aid
special education is going to be new
money that we're going to have to come
from some other direction but we
recognize that we need to start looking
at the differentiated Aid and the
special education Aid category
catastrophic Aid where there is so much
commotion out in our local school
districts right now with the 68% that's
being allocated and and spread prated
back to those communities we're
recognizing these needs but we're also
recognizing that we we have to this move
we can't do it all at once the revenues
do not support that and and and looking
right now Department's been told cut
your budgets back cut your budgets back
8% or even more and so um we're trying
to send the policy message that fiscal
capacity disparity Aid is a necessary
component to assist these communities
that need that
help representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
and so just to comment on that too and
and you know I I appreciate
representative fellows you know question
or or you know wanting to see a breakout
of the fiscal capacity disparity aid but
I think for purposes of of what we're
looking at here it's the use of of State
Grant dollars in their to
totality um and you can see from the top
line here the um the increase of of of
proposed FY 27 over current law uh FY 26
when we count up all of the um the FY
proposed FY 27 the number the total
number of communities that benefit so
there's
245 um cities and towns in the state 200
of them see an increase 45 see a
decrease including Manchester being one
of them but but also the communities
that um um
yeah some others as as well and you can
see that from uh from this chart here
but uh but I think what it's what it
what it does demonstrate is the um um
the the strong recognition that that
that not just the 40 um that benefit
from fiscal capacity to disparate but um
but 200 communities are benefiting from
uh from uh this change in the form well
of course because they're all going they
all have special ed and so they're all
going to get that extra what how much a
thousand, well yeah that's going to make
everybody go up I'm asking
well I'm asking about the fiscal
capacity disparity a how many and how
much is the total amount being add being
allocated for fiscal capacity
disparity that you can't tell me who I
can I can only tell you that I have seen
a spreadsheet that would tell us that
but I don't have it printed in with me
um
the LBA has that spreadsheet right now
and we can get copies for everybody here
there's nothing we're trying to hide
it's just that we've been rushed here
you do have it there repr does it have
the
break
yeah the see the number
yeah uh representative Ames would you go
ahead the numbers I can do that would
would that uh do the trick
representative fellows so he's going to
read 40 of them and give me the N how
much so we're in an executive session
and I think the question is do we need
more information in order to make a
decision today well that would be I
would my opinion on that is yes it's
also possible voting for something that
I haven't even had a chance to see
Mickey has it and you can get it over to
us yeah that he he's better at this yeah
I've got it but uh we've got it too yeah
so Jen and and just in total it's about
$ 13.3 million yeah just right yes
yeah 13.3
yeah um yeah ask no I can you might give
a call to and find out if he's printing
them right now because they're probably
listen so give okay so every everyone
stand by for the moment we're trying to
see if we can get this
printed so I'm I'm also concerned you
know whenever I have L looked at
formulas in the past one of the things I
always do is look at the per pupil
amount that goes per town for the total
usually for the the total Grant and I
don't look at the swep I tend to look at
just the grant because that's Act the
actual money that the state is
representative fellows could you please
pull the mic closer I'm
sorry so one of the things I always have
looked at when I look at different you
know suggestions for formulas and I've
seen many many of them is I look at the
grant which is the amount that the state
actually sends in real dollars to the
school
district for the the benefit of a
particular town
and I I look at the per pupil amount so
I can because that's a way to compare
one town to the other and I think that
given how important this
is I'm very frustrated with the fact
that we're not having an opportunity
because of lack of time I realize to do
that
has
any you just gave that spreadsheet to to
Jen okay so we'll have that shortly here
then one of the things for the public
knowledge th this particular portion of
the formula that makes no changes to
sweat it makes no change this part of
the bill makes no change to sweat we
will have another bill later on our
docket here dealing with sweat
shall we take a
recess I I just wanted to check exactly
what you know if if we want to move
forward you know with a vote or do we
want to pretty much we'll end up taking
lunch and hope for the spreadsheets to
come back my only concern is that if we
do that and then we have further
requests for spreadsheets we may not be
able to accommodate them later in the
afternoon so I would leave it to you
know everybody to the ranking members to
figure that part out
but I want to remind everybody that we
are a combination policy slf funding
committee and that we are proposing here
a process a formula which will be sent
on to division two and they will be
looking in depth that more spreadsheets
than we are going to have time to do
here we do have one that's coming but uh
as far as spending more time in the
spreadsheets I don't think we should I
think we need to get moving forward here
uh um with the this bill uh I I given
the types of revenues we're dealing with
I don't know of any other way that's
going to really being able to allocate
these dollars limited dollars we have um
uh much better than what we've got in
front of us right now and I'm not saying
it's the end all it's certainly not the
the end all but as we've said it's on
the path that we want to be on
okay so I I think that the comments just
made you know lead in the direction that
we know what the bill does we know what
its General intent is it's more or less
status quo funding with two significant
changes the one significant change is a
significant bump up that's a result of a
different methodology for looking at
special ed allowance that results as
representative fellow said a benefit of
uh um over $1,000 per special ed student
throughout the entire State regardless
of their
District the second thing that it does
is it brings back in if in Ana if
enacted it brings back into law a
critical element that is a part of the
balance of the overall funding equation
and that is the capacity of a community
to Bear real estate tax rates that are
in in many cases in excess of uh uh $30
and $20 or more for local ad alone and
if we if we get those two elements into
a bill that moves forward we are making
a very significant change so U I guess I
I I don't want to stifle debate but I I
will ask do we have enough information
in front of us now to go ahead with the
motion on the
amendment representative luno yeah thank
you very much Mr chair I I I I agree
that we have I think we've got
information in front of us now to move
forward with this amendment I agree um
with with representative fellow that we
don't have every piece of information um
but but I think we are at a um at a a um
uh a point in time now where where these
bills have to leave committee so that
they can go to the floor next week and
um and that they can go to finance and
be considered um as house policy to go
into the budget I think having fiscal
capacity disparity Aid uh in any amount
is uh is is important from a policy
standpoint 13 million bucks is a little
thin on a Statewide basis but it may be
all we have to work with I think the
last time uh we did fiscal capacity
disparity Aid is a standalone item I
worked with representative walner in
2019 and it was a $65 million package
Statewide so 13 it was $65 Million last
time we had it it's $13 million now um
uh would love it if the finance
committee could see to it that that they
recognize the importance of fiscal
capacity disparity Aid and could find
the additional money so that um so that
more towns can uh can benefit uh more
towns that are that are struggling under
local property tax burdens so uh so I
think it's important to get this get
this thing moving out of committee and
to the floor and to finance I appreciate
all of those comments representative
Ricky um I just I I
it's it's hard for me to thank you for
recognizing me I'm sorry um it's hard
for me to to say um yes I agree with
both of these people uh um it it's we do
need more information we don't really
have time for more information I'm
hoping that fiscal
will take the time with the more
information um but
I I just wanted to say
that given given
this there are a number of towns um I
would say close to a third
that the actual for fiscal year
2024 is higher than the proposed for
fiscal year
2027 that that's a lot of people that we
are going to need to deal
with if we're not going to deal with it
now we need to deal with it next year
that's a lot of towns where actual
fiscal year
2024 is higher than um proposed fiscal
year
2027 so I think we will need to and I
don't know is there something else
coming along that will change that or is
that just something that next year we're
going to have to deal with that issue so
um valid comments and I agree with your
Long View I would just uh point out for
everybody's benefit that remember that
the hold harmless provision is on a
steady decline and I think that a lot of
what you've described would Trace to
that which is part of current law thank
you very much yeah
and supp yes represent um yeah and when
we talk about that hold harmless
remember we are dropping that 20% now
and and so we're down what around $47
million or thereabouts and when if we
combined that money in with what we had
in extraordinary needs and we've we've
done a lot of that discussion we could
be rounding it off to $250 million or
235 wherever it may stand out and now
trying to divide that up
appropriately yes a number of us have
said wow maybe we should put if it's 250
maybe we should put 150 in fiscal
capacity and the other in the other side
and the fnr stuff
um it's it's just a matter where you
push you know the balloon is got on is
going to it's just that that old story
so but we've also when FY 24 you're
talking about a different population too
than you are right now the enrollments
are dropping in many of these districts
some districts are maintaining I agree
uh but overall our population in the
state is declining Elementary K through
12 so there's a lot of issues associated
with now I do know that spreadsheet is
being run off right now and I don't
think I don't I don't want people to
believe that pushing something through
here without you having the opportunity
to see a spreadsheet I'd sit here five
more minutes before those spreadsheets
arrive so everybody can have a good
healthy look and see how these towns
shape up uh but what we've done here
this bill has really been done uh with
uh uh folks on both sides of the aisle
coming together and saying with the
dollar we have how can we best do
this and and that and that's where we
are yeah yes and I I would just Echo I
think it's it's been a delight to see
that this has been a bipartisan
effort
so is that spreadsheet coming over
representative fellas so I just like to
say that I'm very disappointed that we
wouldn't didn't as a whole committee we
didn't have the time to have that
discussion and to look at the
possibility if we knew we had a certain
amount of money to work with 30 million
or what you know whatever it was to look
at um different options for how to
spread out that money I mean I'm not
saying you know so this is a choice that
was made to put some of it in special ed
and some of it in fiscal disparity with
a different formula than had been used
before there could have been there are
many other options and that we didn't
have a discussion in terms of policy or
by looking at the numbers to determine
what we might want to recommend instead
we just get this put together by I don't
know maybe four
people okay your comments are certainly
understood I'd like just interject one
thing here the money which we're putting
in differentiate Aid is new money it's
not money that's coming out of that $184
million or hold harmless it's on top of
um and for us to be mess not messing
around but working with this formula we
recognize it's going to be difficult now
even under the situation we're in right
now to find another 28 million dollar
there is one way which we've all looked
at and we will be discussing later
today um and so I I don't be jumping
ahead of myself either on this so that
um
I yeah I I I do not know if if there's a
somebody here has a better answer to
this right now let me
know are
comments okay uh then I believe we'll
now move to a vote on the amendment
can we can we check to see can we check
to see we're so close to we can
certainly check I'm I'm not trying to
force it why don't we take a break right
here have our lunch come back and then
get that spreadsheet and then take
action and get the other bills
going okay is everyone comfortable with
the suggestion we're going to recess uh
till 1 o'clock for
lunch you read my
mind
e
e e
so but I don't want you
to you unplugged everything
right yeah I don't want I don't want us
to
get did you
want
e
e e
okay we're going to go ahead and
continue with are our meeting this this
afternoon with these five bills and
right now we are looking at H
563 and there has been a spreadsheet
passed out so everybody can take a
gander at that so you and then what I'm
going to do right now I'm going to pass
this back to uh repres spillsbury who
was chairing that for me seeing that I
had introduced this particular Bill
thank
you okay um
does everybody have their eye on the
spreadsheet
okay I'm going to just allow for a
little bit of Silence if you want to
look at it for a few minutes and the
first person who wants to be recognized
show me with your hand
get something going representative
luno I was wondering if we could as a
committee walk through the Manchester
line I feel
free so I think a lot of us in the
who spent a lot of time on school
funding you know feel you know if you're
not moving the the needle for Manchester
you're not moving the needle Statewide
but but Manchester has has a lot of very
unique um characteristics to it it's
it's got the highest number of students
you know more than any other District
it's got the largest number of students
that are English language Learners um
it's obviously the largest school
district in terms of um capacity uh uh
it's in a city aren't that many cities
um so it's got a it's got a large
commercial tax base and a and a uh I I'm
not sure where Manchester stands uh
today in terms of equalized valuation
per pupil uh but but I thought it would
be worth going through the line and it's
on page four of the of the
spreadsheet and I don't know Mr chair do
you want to sort of take
us I I'm very comfortable having you
make your observations and focusing on
Manchester and then we can look for
other examples so yeah so thank you very
much Mr chair so just looking at at um
at column B you know um U
11,394 kids and then you multiply that
by the
4351 base that brings you to 49.5
million is that a good understanding
there yep um and then we're in column D
6,300 kids uh eligible for free and redu
price meal I think that's low um based
on what we saw in Medicaid direct
certification numbers I think um
Manchester has about a thousand more
that would be eligible but regardless so
it has the potential to grow it would
have the potential to grow but
regardless right now 6300 times the
2441 um that's up in that you know sort
of the row right under the the titles
that brings you brings another 15
million 15.4 million and the same thing
with special education 2500 kids times
the the 31 40 and is that the new number
M yeah yes okay yes yeah just want to
includes both the inflation adjustment
and the bump yep yep there it is um so
up from 21 100 to
3140 um that uh that adds another
approximately $8 million onto it um
English language Learners and you can
see how Manchester dwarfs all the other
communities I don't know where Nasha is
on on um on that line U
1381 Manchester's
got 2000
2077 so times the English length
language learner um um differentiated
Factor you got 1.7 million there so so
those columns together are the result of
the amendment and the the the amendment
over the existing law for the cost of an
adequate education so the cost of an
adequate education man us about $75
million
74.8
million um you net out the uh what they
collect from the state property tax and
that leaves a preliminary Grant from the
state of about 55 million so this would
be non
swept non- swept State revenues so this
is from the basket of other things right
the net that will actually be sent to
the district correct correct so 55
million from the state
um in
that in that 55 million
that would get sent to the state for
adequate education grant there's another
55.4 million which has nothing to do
with what's in column l so column M
while those numbers look really the same
very close they're completely different
it's a doubling yep and so so column m
is the extraordinary needs Grant so this
is a grant that begins at 11 and a half
11.5
,000 per student in in for equalized
property value per pupil in the in a in
a fairly large range because now not
equalized value per people equalized
value per free and red reduced priced
meal pupil did I get that right
$1,730 per yeah yeah and so that comes
out to
55.4 million
so that's
targeted um notice how Manchester
doesn't get any of the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid which is in column n and
that's because Manchester does have a
lot of property value has more than the
median you know property value which I
think is what the the um 1 million to
1.6 million range was was looking to
capture um so there you got the total
adjusted Grant a total adjusted targeted
Grant of 55.4 million and then that
gets uh capped for so this is where the
provision on this is the provision that
representative fellos was asking about
at the top of the spreadsheet we had in
front of us this morning the 3750 and so
now we're on page three of the amendment
lines 20 line 21 through the end for
municipalities with a total admr of
5,000 or more so only Manchester and
Nash are the only ones subtract the
amount necess to limit the total
additional targeted Aid to 3750 per
pupil and so so it takes a a 13 million
is $12 million-ish haircut on that gets
you to 42 million 42.7 million and
targeted so you add that to the number
in column L right and you get
column R which should be the total M GR
from from the state and and R is the
amount sent from the state and then when
swept is added back s is the total
correct yep um so so the reason why
Manchester based on the the you know the
comparison um sheet we saw this morning
uh current law FY 26
proposed uh formula FY 27 you saw that
you saw the grant go down by about $10
million and that is largely attributed
to the um the reduction to their to
their um U extraordinary needs Grant and
uh and it's not that full amount because
obviously they received additional
dollars through through the um uh
special education increase that's how I
I'm I reading that I think that ensures
that everybody follows the architecture
of the spreadsheet thank you I would
also comment that uh um the fiscal
capacity disparity Aid is a new column
that you haven't seen in the prior
spreadsheets this committee has had and
that's column n so that total of 13
million
364 uh how it breaks out amongst those
uh 40 or so communities can be seen very
easily because uh um you can just scan
down that list and most of them are
blank but those that have a figure are
the ones that are benefiting from that
element represent papovich Miller thank
you I would like to very briefly say
that um it is only fair to talk about
haircut that one
1,000
dollar equalized valuation per pupil in
1.6 1 million and 1.6 million
um representative lad yeah if you look
on page two of the bill
on line 24 you can see the extraordinary
needs Grant has the same
2% oops so representative
luno just on that same on this thread
though I think representative fellows
makes a makes a good point that that the
the floor in the ceiling for that evpp
range I'm I'm just catching this as well
so on line 10 and 11 instead of simply
saying the maximum Grant shall be
increased by 2% the wording is the grant
floor the grant ceiling and the maximum
Grant shall be increased so I think
that's what you're getting at right
where are we well no that's that's not
what what I was getting at that that um
that I think for for the for the
purposes of right now and the purposes
of a two-year budget that that you know
we can probably work within that but it
but it should be looked at again in two
years years to to be re-calibrated to
that median point and that starting
point because you might find that Berlin
goes from a million uh evpp to
1.2 and um and and and so it back in
2019 when um when representative lad and
I had um designed a um uh a similar
project we looked at the range was
$600,000 to
1 it was either a million or 1.1 million
it was something like that exactly so so
each iteration of the fiscal capacity
disparity 8 has taken account of those
correct uh increases and I think it's
fair to say that uh two years from now
the legislature will be looking at this
again so I guess the suggestion is we
don't need to get hung up on it two
weeks from now keep I
me but that that said though um when it
does go to when it goes to finance if
you know that that that it it could be
possible to to put in some dynamically
adjusting you know based on you know a a
a median and I mean I think something
like that could be cor yes and I I think
the laugh to my right was suggesting
just that
representative I will um agree that
there is a need to continuously
recalibrate and we all know that we do
look at this every two years whether
without fail so I don't think there is a
question I would say that if you if you
ask me to come up with a way to figure
out how to automatically recalibrate it
in the text of the law so we don't have
to do it manually I could not come up
with something like that with any degree
of confidence so I think while we will
look at everything in the next part of
the
process I would still expect that the
legislature will keep tuning and
figuring out what happens because I
don't know of any way to anticipate in a
text of law everything that may happen
in terms of property values disparities
Evolutions in various parts of the state
so it's it's a guideline which needs to
be continuously retweaked and we will
continue to do that to the best of our
abilities and I would just say uh
speaking personally that I've seen three
or four different iterations of the
formula in the last 10
days and each one has a different
outcome for my
community that's not as important to me
as getting this back into law and
getting this mechanism to be a core part
of the formula so representative I would
just like to add for
that um representative Pap's comment
that I think I can right off the top of
my head think of one way to recalibrate
that you just use the median to the
median or the average to start with and
then say go 7% up and 7% down
okay good future thought representative
Damon so this is possibly right in front
of my nose but column o and P the total
additional targeted Aid and the adjusted
total targeted Aid are 13,000 differ in
the total I mean 13
million did I overlook where that is
because it didn't I didn't find it in
the so so it's just the man
thank you it was in back right in front
of me now was
okay okay so we understand the
offset okay has everybody who wishes to
speak had a chance to
speak seeing no further comment we are
now going to vote on amendment
06508 to House Bill 563
and the clerk can call the the
role chairman spills Barry yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
dry yes representative kcom yes
representative popovic yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes represent of cran yes
represent of Weinstein yes chairman lad
yes 18 yay zero
nay 18 yay zero nay the amendment passes
and we now uh can move for to a new
motion yes thank you very much uh
chairman spillsbury I'd like to make the
motion uh on HP 563 move that forward
ought to PE ought to pass as amended
with
0650 as the amendment I'll second that
seconded by representative luno so the
motion is
otpa on HP
563 in inclusive of amendment
06508 would anybody like to speak to the
motion no I think we've had an ample
discussion on that I think we all
understand that this is the a good move
forward it's not the answer but it's the
best we can do at this time thank you
thank you other comments representative
Ames I I want to just Concur and uh and
and emphasize once again that this is a
way station on the pathway to a
comprehensive effort to do the right
thing by school funding which I believe
we are not doing thus far this takes us
a step in the right direction so that's
why I'm supporting
it thank you other
comments representative fellas yes um
along that same line I would think I
would call this a
Band-Aid and we will be back to revisit
the
wound thank
you further comments okay seeing none
the motion is
otpa on HB
563 will the CL clerk please call the
rooll chairman billsberry yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Earth yes representative
dry yes representative kcom yes yes
representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes representative gritan yes
representative Weinstein yes chairman
lad yes 18 years Z
nay
18 yay zero nay um so the motion of otpa
carries and representative lad will you
be writing the report yes I will thank
you very
much okay thank you everyone for their
patience through that uh
discussion well we're at 20% of the
bills done now Mr chair like whole
harmless we're down 20% Mr chair uh HB
739 is the next one under doet here this
is relative to excess funds paid to the
mun pardon me you don't have the
amendment on that okay we don't have the
amendment so we're going to jump to the
top one then 773 can can I ask Jen uh OS
tells me this amendment was transmitted
about two hours ago and
uh one
second was that in that bundle you just
received
no uh
um the amendment number is
0688 the amendment that we were provided
earlier was the incorrect
one 680 which Bill
we which we don't know which Bill you're
on well we're we're trying to figure out
where we are okay yeah
yeah I announced 773 so we're jumping to
the top Bill there
773 and amendments amendment is coming
around okay 773 is a bill relative to
the aid aid to school districts for
costs of special education
our old catastrophic Aid
discussion
so with
that
who sorry good question I'll make it you
can write okay I'd like to recognize
represent spillsbury for a
motion thank you I move OTP on
773 I'll second that okay we have a
motion made by by representa spillsbury
second by representa luno as OTP on 773
I recognize representa spillsbury thank
you Mr chair I would like to further
move Amendment
0714 H which has just been passed around
and once we have a second I'd like to
speak to and explain the amendment I'll
second it thank you very much we have a
a second to the amendment made by
represent luno primary motion was made
by represent spills on the amendment
14h represent spillsbury you recognized
for discussion thank you Mr
chair this amendment to 773 Blends
elements that were found in both 773
representative lad's Bill and 742
representative luno bill so if I can uh
walk you through the amendment
um if you have
773 uh on your desktop good good to have
that open if you have 742 even better
but I'll refer to
both the
amendment uh retains the three and a
half times average cost threshold it's
in current law and that and is just to
make the numeral
clear uh it deletes the the sentence in
line 8 through 11 that is in current law
and that's the sentence that provides
for pration in the event of a shortfall
so that's gone it creates a new sentence
in lines 11 through
15 and uh this concept was in
773 but it was uh misplaced in the wrong
subsection B so it's been incorporated
into uh uh subsection Roman
3A and it's also been changed from the
figure in 773 was 85% this is
80% now obviously the idea is to have an
appropriation each year that fully funds
the commitments made in the formula for
catastrophic aid but in the event of a
short fall this basically U places a
floor of 80% says the state will back up
at least to
80% if there's if it's if there's
adequate uh money uh in the
appropriation then it could be 100% this
just sets a
floor um and uh so it moves away from
the uh elimination of pration entirely
and there could therefore be a
pration if the uh appr if the
appropriation fell short
down towards the 80% level and so now on
page
two the new language found in lines 9
through
19 is directly taken from representative
luno Bill light wording adjustments from
742 and that in turn comes out of the
EFA statute and so it provides the same
process as for the efas if there's a
shortfall um we go to the the governor
goes to the education trust fund if the
education trust fund is at zero then
further goes to the general fund so this
is to back stop the 80%
commitment so I I think it's been a
well-coordinated uh Cooperative uh
effort uh with representative luno to
take the two parts of the bill and blend
them thank you very much represent luno
do you have any further
discussion uh you know I
um I I I I I think the intent of this is
is is is right on the right on I would I
would certainly have liked to see a
higher uh pration floor but 80 is higher
than zero the floor right now is zero
and um and so that's that's the reason
I'd support it I'm I'm uh
just looking
at how in section one we use the word
we've got the word
appropriation which was um not in the U
the 742 Bill we only used a draw of the
education trust fund and then you've got
um you've got in section
two the words from that draw that rely
on the education trust fund
um and just wondering if the is is the
appropriation if in any year the amount
appropriated is is what's being refer I
guess it's question what's being
referred to on page one line 11 the
amount appropriated is that the same as
as um what's talked about on line on
page two line 10 uh yes the amount
appropriated for distribution in line 11
of page one is the same uh that's being
referred to in page two line 10 uh the
amount necessary you know is hereby
appropriated the same so the draw occurs
only where there's a
shortfall right the draw against the
education trust fund is a provision for
what happens if the appropriation is
insufficient to F meet the claims I'm
not sure that's true because in in line
six on page two Roman 4 the state shall
appropriate an amount for each fiscal
year that's been deleted and so that was
the that was the budget appropriation
and that's the thing that made it
susceptible to a shortfall if it's
appropriated from the education trust
fund by defa by definition there's no
shortfall I I I I I think cuz because
because of the way the ETF
is yes representative McGuire thank you
so I I think the in this section
language makes it clear because both of
these things are in RSA
186-188 right so I think it's pretty
clear that they're the
same further
discussion representative fellows so um
I just had a question about a
warrant um the
governor's if it's appropriate things
that are does it need to be appropriated
to the Department of Education via a
warrant so if
I man yes go ahead
let's say an appropriation of $50
million is
made and let's say claims come in at $80
million
so the appropriation is less than
80% right so the appropriation is
funding the first 50 million and the
warrant drawn against the education
trust fund makes up the Gap from there
to the 80% promise
further
discussion not seeing
any represent Damon thank
you I just want to say that while this
is a considerable Improvement in
predictability to school districts of
coverage of catastrophic special
education
costs it still does leave the district
paying
more than they expected to but it's
certainly an
improvement represent yes papich thank
you um I hear what you're saying and I
appreciate that you're acknowledging
that this is obviously clear Improvement
as a former Finance director of the town
obviously not the school district but
the concepts are the same if I would see
this law I would budget as if I was
going to receive 80% and consider
anything over 80% to be more or less a
winfall so it completely eliminates that
negative surprise you can get if a
school district is disciplined and
budgets accordingly to the minimum they
know they will receive then they can
only have a pleasant surprise and we
will always I want to make that very
clear do everything we can to
appropriate the right amount so this is
paid at 100% we've we've always try to
do that but the floor being there gives
you the absolute certainty that you
won't have a negative prise below the
floor so you can budget to the floor and
then hope you'll get a bit more but
you'll you know it we do the best we can
in The Current financial situation thank
you I I just want to Echo the same thing
the objective is not to invite lower
Appropriations the presumption is we're
going to appropriate what we expect this
is only dealing with those situations
where there's an a surprise of uh claims
that exceed the appropriation
and and and I I I think I would also
offer the thought that there's been a
lot of discussion in this committee that
we're not going to lose sight of over
the question of how to better measure
what's going on in U in the special Aid
field and I think we will be working
towards other ways of trying to improve
reporter reporting and data so that uh
we can improve upon the law but I think
this is what we can do at this stage
further
discussion i' like to just add on to
what uh reveron spillsbury just said
that it's my intention to put together a
subcommittee to look at uh how we're
dealing with special education Aid where
we're getting our data from looking at
these IEPs that are written that are in
the local school districts to make sure
that the expenses
parallel uh our requirements for when
we're matching it up against a specific
category area of of a
disability um that we also ensure that
um that we
can not fall into this Pitfall that
we're in right now where we're having
68% at pration rate where districts this
is the number one issue I've heard from
my communities is we're getting hammered
on this one and and I I think we all
agree and I I just this bill was
originally put in by myself
and it echoed a bill HB
344 dated back in
2013 and that's when representative
guile and I put together a bill to try
to address this issue of pration and it
hadn't existed at that time and we
didn't do it back then and the language
that we together had put in was 80% now
I'd love to see 90% or a higher number
but I think in in all honesty this is
the one which has the best chance of
making it through um we do need to
address this in even in the light that I
am concerned that the monies which we
spend on this a school district
shouldn't get nailed with an amount
which they don't
have and I reflect and I've mentioned
this committee and for those are new
here I have two little town a little
town in my district called pymont
and they had two of these youngsters
come into the school in the same year
from outside their school district and
all of a sudden they had to provide
these Services of course it's based upon
previous year's allocation but they had
come up with over between the two of
over
$250,000 because we all know that the
school district's accountable for the
first what 96 million that's 70,000 plus
that 26 left over between the 20 80% up
to 100% and 10 times I mean so it was
just very difficult for them and and
it's difficult for all communities so uh
this is a very important bill to me and
I think it is for our communities out
there but it's not the answer we need to
get in there and find out what's going
on I mentioned to you before that
there's States like Arkansas that one
out of every 10 IEPs are audited to
ensure that they
reflect um
the the standards for that particular
handicapping condition and and they also
reflect the standards set by the state
for
reimbursement so thank you very
much any further discussion on this bill
then Madam
clerk we have the amendment before us
which is uh let's see
07114 I believe that's the amendment in
front of me um and the motion is t or
excuse me ought to pass on the
amendment for
773 representative spil baring
yes
yes yes representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan
yes representative peoples yes
representative
bluno yes representative Ames yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellows yes representative Damon yes
representative bricky yes representative
crian yes representative Weinstein yes
chairman lad yes 18a zero
name
okay okay I'd like to recognize
representative spsb for a
motion so I move
otpa on HB
773 as amended by Amendment 0
714 is there a second second the
motion's been made by representative
spillsbury and second by representative
Damon and the motion made is
OTP uh see a for HB
773 further
discussion not seeing
any Madam Madam clerk call roll
representative spills be yes
representative mcguy yes representative
Earth yes representative dry yes
representative kcom yes representative
papovich yes representative Brown yes
representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes representative cran yes
representative Weinstein yes chairman
lad yes 18 yay Z
nay I'll do the blur for
you okay uh the next bill we have in
front of us is HB
739 okay see am okay it's relative
excess funds paid to municipalities for
the use of
school
districts yeah
okay I Look to represent spills spry for
a
motion thank you Mr chair I move OTP on
HB
739 second that okay we have a motion
that's been made made by representa
spills OTP and second by represent luno
representative spills do you have any
further
discussion thank you very much Mr chair
uh we're passing out an amendment right
now that uh
did it go that way it has gone this way
yes oh it did
yes they got am down
there hasn't reached every desk yet
right okay let me wait
just going right now right yeah okay
everybody should have the amendment
right now perhap spilsbury do you have
further discussion on I would like to
move Amendment
0680 to HP 739 thank you is are there
any seconds second that and represent
luno seconds that motion made by
representative spillsbury on
0680 H the amendment for
739 represent spilburg thank you Mr
chair I I believe the bill itself was
pretty thoroughly discussed in our work
session uh so I won't re-explain it
except to summarize that this reinstates
Provisions that uh were repealed in
2011 uh regarding the uh remit of swept
that exceeds the adequacy grant due to a
particular community in the course of uh
our work uh we heard from Mark magello
Department of
Education and Bruce canor from the
Dr that uh the timing of a full annual
cycle was such that it would be
difficult to implement this or would
cause reassessments of uh of what to
expect in the communities that already
have their FY 26 budgets uh um ready to
go to voters so we have an amendment
that simply adds oneline
applicability that the first swept shall
be remitted March 15
2027 so the bill takes
effect uh July 1st 2025 but the
obligation to remit the excess swept
amount is deferred to FY 27 and would
have to occur by March 15
27 further
discussion represent
Ames I just think it's important uh to
make clear what representative
spillsbury really has made clear but I
want to underscore it that we're
delaying this the
effective in effect the
effective uh implementation of this
change
to a point where it can be appropriately
implemented not because we're trying to
save a little money in the short term
that's what I think that needs to be on
the record thank
you yeah that's correct that that that
is correct you know it couldn't be
implemented right now seeing that we're
going ahead another week or so here for
Town meetings and they're already
projecting based upon estimations and uh
this would cause a huge comp Fusion if
we put it down for FY 26 I don't think
it's possible to do it without having
total chaos out there in the
woods further
discussion okay so we have an amendment
in front of us I hear no further
discussion on the
amendment Madam clerk we're ready when
you are we're voting on the amendment
0680 H is to 739 Representatives
spillsbury yes representative Maguire
yes representative Earth yes
representative dry yes representative
kcom yes representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows
no representative Damon yes
representative Ricky
yes restive gritan yes resident of
Weinstein yes chairman lad yes 17 y One
n thank you now we have the main Motion
in front of us would be OT go ahead
thank you Mr chair I'd like to move otpa
on HP
739 as amended by Amendment
0680 I'll second that okay we have an
amendment uh a main motion now on 739
otpa given
0680 as amended to it any further
discussion from the maker of the motion
no thank you from the second IT
addresses I think the one concern I had
with the underlying
Bill any further
discussion if you all look at and recall
we had discussed in a previous Bill
increasing
special education differentiate Aid in
the amount of $28
million that's what your excess
is further
discussion not hearing any Madam clerk
would you please call the role
representative spills bearing yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
dry yes representative kcom yes
representative bovich yes representative
Brown yes representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows no repres
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes representative cran yes
representative Weinstein yes chairman
lad yes 17 Y and one
nay thank you very much going on to the
next bill hb6 pardon me oh
yeah sir Minority
Report represent fellows you will write
that okay
by tomorrow noon at the very very latest
in fact in need be Laur I got to review
it and Jif 4 wants at noon so it has to
be by at least 10:00 tomorrow morning so
I can look at
it okay good and same thing for any
other reports that are due today so the
minority motion
is the minority motion is itl correct
yes it must be yes it will be yes yes
yes okay
okay okay we're on
675 this bill is increasing the total
revenue raised under the Statewide
education property tax requiring
municipalities to remit excess Statewide
education property tax payments to the
Department of Revenue Administration
limiting the authority of school
districts to make certain Appropriations
and increasing base adequacy costs per
pupil relative to Universal eligibility
for Education Freedom account program oh
excuse me I jumped down the line I was
just adding it all right in
there limiting the authority of school
districts to make certain Appropriations
increasing base adequacy costs per
pupil all
righty look to represent McGuire for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
move ought to pass and with Amendment
well let's let's do the ought to pass
first okay is there a second second okay
we have motion brought forward by
representa Maguire second by
representative F OTP on
675 Breon McGuire recognized for
discussion can I make my Mo yes you made
oh all right I'd like to move Amendment
at
it's the one we had last this this was
passed out the last time we
met second my Mo oh
second okay we have a a motion made on
0548 H the motion made by represent
McGuire and second by represent Earth
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so this is a bill that had uh
numerous pieces and this amendment
reduces it to just one specific one
which is um the cap on
spending in the local schools school
districts um and the cap is
um based on um the fiveyear average
appropriation as changed in the future
by um
admr and um and also
inflation over over again kind of with a
5year
smoothing and in general
um this addresses um one of the biggest
uh complaints
by my constituents and I'm assuming
yours as well which is um the the
accelerating rate of property
taxes um and most of most of which is um
the result of of spending in
schools um we have schools in the state
uh the average spending in schools is
about somewhere between 21 and
$22,000 per student but we have we have
um schools that spend up near $30,000
per student and we have schools that
spend under
$133,000 per student and there's very
little uh correlation between if any
between
um
performance and spending there are
schools under $133,000 per student that
have performances above average and
there's schools below there's schools
that are above $29,000 per student and
and um that have above average
performance and their schools below so
the the
um there is not necessarily a strong
correlation if any between
spending and performance but there is
between spending and property taxes and
so this bill would limit the growth of
that spending and therefore limit the
growth of property taxes thank you Mr
chair further
discussion further yes represent luno so
thank you very very much Mr chair so you
know we talked about this um this
amendment uh last week when uh when all
of a sudden this committee hit the
breakes um on it and and it hit the
brakes I think because of three um main
points and the first one was that it
locks in the disparities that uh we have
across the state when it comes to access
to resources to fund School budgets and
we have some school budgets that are
that are somewhere in the 15 on on
$155,000 um uh per student
and we have other school budgets in
other towns that are closer to
$45,000 per student so and and those
School budgets largely are um are are
are at those numbers because different
cities and towns have different access
to resources some are more
well-resourced than others a lot of
those have very strong budgets others
struggle with the highest property taxes
in the state and still end up with a
budget that doesn't um doesn't do right
by their kids that was the first point
that was made second point that was made
that I think was a very very important
point is that what do we what do
districts do about special education
costs those are an absolute must pay
type of um type of item and so so I
would offer that since those are must
pay and regular education is maybe not
must pay then regular education would
suffer in districts that don't have um
the um the access to the resources that
uh that they need so places like Newport
would continue to suffer even more
places like Newcastle would uh would not
not suffer at all it locks in those
inequities um because of the unfair
budget landscape because of the special
education cost and then finally what
type of look is this um you know I we
don't have to look very far than um than
to the K Serge Regional School District
and what happened during the first week
of January when there was a budget cap
local budget cap um on the in their
deliberative session and they had U over
1,200 people show up for the
deliberative session 1,200 I think voted
against it and 100 um for it and they
rejected that budget cap by an
overwhelming sentiment of the Comm
community so so from my the what the
public is saying is they're rejecting
that budget cap and I'll tell you um
representative Maguire you talked about
a strong correlation well I'll tell you
there's no correlation between what you
just said about what your constituents
uh are doing and what your constituent
actually did to uh to reject the budget
cap in um uh in Epsom so so I you know I
think this is very shortsighted I think
this is very unfair I think there could
be a time there could be a time when uh
when this type of thing uh when a when a
budget cap could be looked at but first
we have to fix Scare Fair school funding
so that we at least put every school
District in on on on a on a on an equal
playing field uh where uh where they
have access to the resources they need
so that they can have the budgets that
they need rather than locking them in
thank you thank you very much further
discussion from the committee
representative Pap I just wanted to uh
thank my colleague from hopkington for
uh you
know recapping the discussion we had
last week which was a reasonably
accurate recap of the discussion and
also Al for bringing up the fact that um
a
66% requirement to override the cap
which is built into the law can easily B
surpass because Kar shows us that they
were what over 90% in favor of the point
I'm trying to make is that when there is
a clear need because we've been behind
and now our properties are coming up and
we can increase the budget more when
special education things grow
unexpectedly and they are trying to
crowd out part of the regular
education the town has a very
straightforward Escape valve of 66% that
they can trigger and the current data is
that every vote that rejected the
spending cap did pretty much by a much
larger margin and 66% so the relief
mechanism is perfectly adequate and it
allows towns to address those very
legitimate concerns that are being
brought up we are leaving it to the
towns to decide we are just making it a
bit more difficult to keep increasing
the taxes and the expenses the way it's
done right now thank you further
discussion representa
Damon thank you Mr
chair I'm vigorously opposed to this
bill as noted it is perpetuating the
existing very significant inequities
between funding and districts now this
is the absence of a thoughtful
comprehensive approach to managing
education spending districts already
have the option to vote in in a cap a
number of districts have voted down caps
this year in a resounding way why are we
talking about taking away their local
control that we forever emphasizing on
other
things and I think to believe that it is
a
reasonable easy thing to achieve a 66%
majority it is in no way easy I was part
of that effort in karge I was a leader
of the effort in cuden 3 years ago
it takes a remarkable amount of time
energy Grassroots democracy
communication and there is no guarantee
it's way too high of a hurdle does not
benefit our kids to do this further
discussion from the committee
representative
fellows yes I would I can't support this
another reason is that it's um on line
16 of the first page one of the reasons
to have a cap one of the
measures for the cap is the percentage
change in the
admr um if a school
district's admr drops
5% they C you they're not going to be
able to cut the budget in a way that
reflects that because you can't take a
teacher and cut 5% of a teacher from a
classroom this um it's just not an
appropriate measure to use
um if if you did happen to think there
were some measures that you could use to
um control the budget which I don't I
think it's a local
issue further
discussion yes represent luno so so
thanks very much you know I I really
question why why you know this is needed
and um and you know what back um
back four years ago the um the educ
Freedom account program was touted as
something that was going to save
taxpayers money so why isn't that
getting the job done wouldn't I mean
that was the whole excuse for bringing
vouchers in that it was going to reduce
the burden on local property taxpayers
apparently that hasn't happened um so
that we're looking for other ways to
somehow shut out our local property
taxpayers from being able to decide what
they want to spend on their their public
schools and how they want to support
their kids I I think this is just a this
is a Draconian measure forward it's a
terrible measure and it's it's just part
of a continued um series of I think
failed attempts to uh to not do right by
Granite
Staters further discussion from the
represent
Ames yeah I just want to reiterate I
think I said this last week when we
talked about it but it's been said but I
it uh needs to be underscored that
essentially this
will not quite freeze in but just about
lock in the inequities that we have in
this system and uh it seems to me that
our the first job that we have that
we're all struggling with
is is addressing those inequities in an
affirmative way not through some
arbitrary cap arbitrary system that's uh
hard to navigate and uh that uh takes
enormous effort when people are opposed
or for uh one a particular cap in a
particular Town it just diverts all that
energy and our energy and uh whatever uh
abilities we have should be funneled
into making for a better uh funding
system for the entire Public School
Enterprise thank you thank you
representa
mahagan thank you Mr chairman I I want
to express my gratitude to um
representative luno for articulating my
own uh misgivings as as I expressed it
last Friday because you did better than
I did um but I want to say why I've come
across at this I believe that we're at a
time in this state of absolute crisis
where special ed increase goes up
uncontrolled every single year at in my
town 28% each year some has to be done
and I I don't see this as a stop Gap
measure I I see this as a as a as an act
of almost fiscal War saying it can't go
on like this we have to do something on
the state level where we've reached a
point where this can't continue and I
think that this is something that's
appropriate and temporary I don't see
this as an absolute answer I certainly
is not a bandage but it is saying we've
had enough the taxpayers in my town have
had enough another 12% increase it's
going to it's going
to it's going to be untenable with the
people of my town and so we actually
have to say looking at what the problem
is we're going to have to make a motion
that stops IT this is an extreme measure
but I see it as something temporary and
important for it today further
discussion resent
Damon thank you again Mr
chair with respect to the
representative's most recent
remarks absolutely concur that this is a
very extreme
measure and I believe it is a profound
mistake to take an extreme action when
we can see the severe consequences right
in front of us districts are mandated to
provide the special education services
that children
require so if this cap is in place and
Leed costs increase and we all agree
that we need to work on better
understanding that and I'm really
pleased to hear we'll have a
subcommittee addressing
that but when special ed costs go up in
a district with a budget cap the
students who are not receiving special
ed services are going to be the
underfunded ones and if you are already
in a district where the cost per student
is on the lower end of things the 15 17
$199,000
those students are going to be penalized
by this in a very severe
way that is simply not fair and
Equitable all our students deserve
quality education and this does not
facilitate
that thank you further discussion from
the committee not see any Madam clerk
would you please call the
RO got this on the
amendment 0548 8 H the motion is OTP on
that
Amendment representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
dry yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative
fellows yes bows
no representative Damon no
representative bricky nope
representative cran no representative
Weinstein no chairman lad yes T eight
okay uh repesent McGuire do you want to
make a motion
here I think the motion's here but uh
ought to pass with Amendment yes that'
be a great motion okay second second
represent so rep rep McGuire makes
motion of otpa with the amendment being
0548 H2 HB 675 and second by representa
ER further discussion
not seeing
any any further
discussion mam clerk we're ready when
you're
ready sure I I'll quick discussion sure
go ahead thank you very much uh Mr chair
in a nutshell this is a dis a disaster
for New Hampshire Public
Schools
second okay let's let's take some action
on the bill itself please thank you um
Madam clerk would you please call the
role the the motion is otpa on
675 representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes yes
representative F yes representative dry
yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative am
no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no Representative bricky no
representative cran no representative
Weinstein no chairman lad
yes 10 Y and eight
nay thank you very much we'll be who's
going to be a Minority Report by of
Damon for itl okay repon Damon
itl okay
Maguire okay the next bill up on the
docket here is
hb15 this is relative to Universal
eligibility for Education Freedom
account
program is there a motion
okay I'll
pass I'll pass the gav off to
you uh thank you um I am looking for a
motion on HB 675 representative
lad
11 thank you no uh representative lad HP
115 okay on hb15 I make a motion to OTP
thank you
second
M the
second representative papich
Miller
okay well see you got it now I handed
the g off cuz I made the motion Okay so
we have uh we have the motion in the
second and do we have an amendment
representative
lad yes we do yes we do
um I'd like to move uh
otpa OTP on 06
51h this is to
115 Amendment 0651 H is there a second
second seconded by representative
Maguire
don't no we don't have okay what we got
to do is hand that
out who's got
that it was
just I I got I got one right
here Jen can we get some copies made of
this
place we had a whole slug of amendments
on this thing
yeah yeah well we got the amendment here
so we're going to take while this that
they're running that off we'll take a
10-minute
break who moved that
amendment I I seconded I second who was
who motioned I made the motion oh you
did oh that's right you did the OTP was
lad of thear amendment
was I would make the motion I would
really rather that's okay doesn't bother
me one way got a couple of others here
yeah and there's one I said I do the
uh
e
e e
okay I'd like to call the committee back
to order we're going to resume executive
session uh on
hb15 I'm sure everyone benefited from
the brief recess so uh I'm going to call
on representative lad um to uh speak to
his motion on Amendment 06518
thank you very much uh representa
spillsbury uh the amendment I'll be very
brief here uh the amendment is brief in
fact what it does do on line seven right
now you know the uh uh household income
threshold level for eligibility the
median family income is set at 350% for
an EFA education Freedom account program
uh this bill uh would this amendment
would propose that the 350
uh uh per medium family in housec come
of federal property guidelines uh set by
the Federal Register would be increased
to 400% for FY
26 after June 30
2026 there' be no income threshold need
be met in subsequent years for K through
12 so it basically is 400% for the first
year FY 26 fy2 seven the the uh EFA
program becomes
Universal uh any any student who's a
resident meets other other other
qualifications in the statute uh May
participate in the EFA program that's
it okay further discussion on the
amendment representative luno so thanks
very much um for uh for both those
um periods FY um 26 and FY 27 do you uh
have a um a fiscal note and an estimate
of the number of uh of U efas that would
be um uh open or the number of students
that would Avail themselves of of
efas I mean a fiscal note would be very
helpful I representative lad
is going to speak to your
question okay
um in terms of the first year of going
up to
400% I I don't see a steep climb in St
students that are going to be doing that
seeing that most of the students which
are coming from households that uh we're
talking about 185 to you know 30
130% uh down to that is free and reduced
and so we're talking about few kids
coming additional see we're only upping
by 50% in the second year uh we're
opening up to all and that includes
those that are in private schools right
now and that's
approximately um 1, 1400 students in our
state excuse me excuse me um de did
number of students in New Hampshire
non-public schools is
17,6
70 that's the number of students of
which I see 9,000 of those not eligible
for EFA seeing that they are
non-residents of this state that are
attending private schools to the
24,990
students and
wait hold on hold on I was recognized
represent is
speaking and we also have some students
that are already in the uh in the
program and the preschool population
which is not eligible is around 1500
students so and in looking at that I can
see that you I I would subtract out
those 9,000 students which are not
eligible uh uh seeing that I've just
mentioned why uh we're we're talking
much less I know that there's been some
that say it's going to be $100 million
that's going to cost us um I I I think
that's incorrect very incorrect as we're
talking about thousands of ineligible
preschool students out of state students
and we're talking about students already
in the EA program and we're assuming
every eligible student would take an EFA
and that's not the case and it's never
been the case in any state that's had
EFA programs so I think the figures are
absolutely blown out of proportion here
in terms of those the cost you say this
PR is going to cost the average cost per
pupil uh state federal and local
spending is around $26,000 while EA
average costs around
$5,200 I see a huge savings there um and
and further average State adequacy
adequacy education grant funding for FY
24 was
$6,196 while EFA Grant average was
$524 I don't see this as a program
that's going to cost regor education uh
any kind of uh issue in terms of funding
streams Etc um at the very very maximum
the maximum it could cost would be about
$1 million in the second year when we
open up uh to um
Universal
so few facts you have follow up on that
yes representative so thank you very
much so uh so we've had the voucher
program in place since um uh 20 uh
uh 21 22 23 no 22 fy22 23 and 24 and and
we're in the fourth year uh of it right
now um it uh it I think in in
fy2 it has a cost to the state of about
$27
million approximately is that is that
right and um and so so given the fact
that you're estimating far less but but
significant savings I was wondering what
what savings can you point to in terms
of local taxpayers in terms of what the
program currently costing the state $27
million how has that resulted in savings
at the local level to date we've got
four years of
data is that a question for me yes a
question representative lad you care to
answer I think we're never going to get
to where we're all on board on this I
believe very strongly that there's a lot
more to the EFA program than you're
trying to drive at these costs here I
think you're looking at students that
have not been successful in their
current situation as far as learning in
the schools they may be resident of uh
having this Choice allows them to the
flexibility to have programs where
they're not being bullied they're having
the opportunity to uh learn in a way
that's more uh uh appropriate for their
learning style with a teaching style
it's appropriate for them there's all
kinds of reasons why this program has
been successful and I think the success
is measured by the data that we're
getting out of the children's
scholarship fund in terms of the testing
which they're doing the portfolios that
they're H having and you I hear
oftentimes why aren't you testing all
these kids well we don't do that in the
public school system K through k through
two there is no Statewide achievement
test at all the achievements that start
tests start in grades three and going
upwards in up through 8th grade and then
once in 11th grade there's more
accountability I believe and what I see
in the EFA program that I've seen in
some public
schools in some Public Schools where we
see the proficiency level in mathematics
so very very low the proficiency scores
and language arts being so low why would
anybody then want their 9-year-old child
going to a fourth grade in a school
where that proficiency is at that level
they're looking for options and I think
that's what we got to be looking at we
got to look what is the best fit for the
child it goes back to all the things
we've done with education tuition uh uh
programs to uh open enrollment programs
to all the areas that we've gone as far
as alternative education there's
rationale reasoning for it I would hope
that the education Choice programs are
showing that this these programs are are
making or creating more competition
between the public schools say hey we're
going to have to elevate our product
that we're putting
out and and uh so there there'll be it
I'm not going to answer your question in
terms of dollars and cents I'm I'm
answering in terms of what is best for
the child and the parent and Mr chair so
I I I had a couple questions but I would
like to get a comment um in so so go
ahead U thank you thank you very much Mr
chair So currently at um at the when the
when the program started at
300% I think in the second year the
program Drew about $13 million in state
funds um it went to
350% and then and then Drew $27 million
in in state funds so going to 400% I
would expect at least that that level of
of increment in the um in the first year
so now I want to swing it into um into
the second year that um that there are
according to the Department of Education
uh the number of New Hampshire students
attending private schools non-public
schools is
16,640 N1 adding both those two numbers
together and multiplying by what um what
representative lad said the average uh
voucher of $5,200 comes out to
approximately $102 million so I think
that's that's actually
reasonably um arrived at uh cost
assessment for this now I want to talk
about the kids who are actually leaving
the public schools that's some
information believe it or not that that
you can actually get from the Department
of Education cuz thankfully we had these
things called phase out grants that uh
that provided State dollars back to
public schools for every student that um
that left and when you look at the phase
out grants it becomes pretty clear that
fewer than 5% of the uh of the students
um in the education Freedom account
program actually left their their public
school to take a voucher um and to seek
some alternative to their their public
school what frankly um has me puzzled
right now is why on the children's
scholarship fund um um FY
24990 so this is the the the non-taxable
entity filing that every
501c3 has to file with the uh with the
federal government they show that they
owe the state um back the state of New
Hampshire a million almost a million
dollars in refunds and um I'm wondering
if those are from closed um EFA accounts
after a student has left their public
school and then realized oh this wasn't
a good decision and um and and go back
into their public school because I think
that's one of the one of the the reasons
why
efas uh can be closed so you know so I
think a a really careful analysis on
this shows and and very well-reasoned
analysis based on the Doe's own numbers
is that is that the program in the first
year year would would see at least um um
15 most likely 20 million so this is FY
26 um uh$ 15 to20 million increase in um
in state costs uh based on students who
are largely already attending um private
schools that in the second year when the
when the income limit is completely
blown away and uh and now 16,640
,000 Plus in homeschools would be
eligible that that would go um up to 102
million and and frankly based on the
program's history hardly anybody is
leaving their Public Schools uh to take
a voucher and um and and I I think even
a good percentage of those appear to be
returning to their Public Schools given
the liability that the children schol
the nearly million dollar liability that
children's scholarship has to the state
of New Hampshire
thank you representative fellas did you
have your hand up yes u i just since
representative lad didn't want to
respond with the numbers I just thought
I might share my thoughts on that I
frequently hear the average expenditure
per pupil which is about
$23,000 come up as a comparison to the
cost of a voucher and they have nothing
to do with each other I think many many
people in the public think that somehow
the state or school districts are saving
the difference between those two numbers
and that's totally not
true the difference the comparison
that's happening that should be
considered is that whatever is paid out
in a voucher is an expenditure by the
state and if that student came from a
school district then then some amount of
money which could be anything from 0 to
$133,000 could be subtracted from the
state adequacy Grant going to the
community that that student came from
and those are the two comparisons there
is no savings going on it costs the
state money if there if the students
coming from a public school it's that um
municipality is could be losing money so
this is not a win-win for anybody except
for the people many of whom have high
incomes that would be receiving these
vouchers thank you um we have several
comments here I'll take them in order
representative papich Muller and
representative dry and representative
thank you I uh just wanted to make
sure that we
um all understand what a voucher is
especially for the members of the public
that may be watching these proceedings a
voucher is a payment directly from the
state to wherever the money is being
paid the efas are not vouchers now I
cannot stop anybody from calling them
vouchers we have the right to call
anything we want anything we want but if
we use the generally accepted definition
of voucher this does not apply to the
EFA are payments to the parent the
parent then can use those funds they
receive from the state to pay for any
qualified educational expenses the huge
difference in this case is that the
state does not pay for that you know
whatever educational expense the state
pays the parent the parent then decides
to pay somebody else this has a
huge it has a huge impact in terms of
legal understanding of what the term is
and again I would not use the word
vouchers to go forward but I will not
object to my colleagues continuing to
use it thank
you representative JY thank you very
much I think you seriously underestimate
the homeschooling Community when you
assume that all 3,000 of them would jump
at a chance to get an EFA they haven't
jumped now and I don't think they will
jump later it's not a monolith and I
think we do disrespect to the
independent thinking of homeschoolers to
think that we would all Run and Jump
after that immediately as a
group representative Cen just
exp thank you Mr chair I if I could I
would just like to ask um representative
luno for some clarification if I
understood you correctly you said the
phase out grants um and how many
students have left is fewer than 5% was
that fewer than 5% of the state total of
of students no it's fewer than 5% % of
of students with um uh in the voucher
program it's far fewer than 5% of the
number of students in the state okay I
mean there's 160,000 students in the
state so five correct I wanted
clarification to understand what you
were referring to thank
you U I would just suggest there's a lot
of facts a lot of uh statistics and data
and it's very hard in a public forum
like this to anchor down what real um I
uh I think we've heard there's
potentially 177,000 students we've heard
X thousands of of them are out of state
or not eligible Etc so I think everyone
has done their homework coming to this
session today and you've got your own
understanding of what those tradeoffs
are and I don't think uh um you know
dueling facts is going to help us
progress this afternoon so if you think
you're bringing something new to the
discussion uh please by all means raise
your hand and if it's just the dueling
facts I again I think we've all done our
homework representative
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for
your level
tone
um the student
outcomes that we don't track in EFA
students in New
Hampshire but have been tracked in a
number of other states can
here that's unusual is that better
sorry the student outcomes that we don't
track EFA student outcomes in New
Hampshire in other states with similar
programs the outcomes have been dismal
when they have been tracked they have
not shown comparable results to public
schools to the point that a number of
states have stopped tracking outcomes
because it looks so bad for those
programs I don't know why we wouldn't
want to know how our students are doing
in whatever educational environment
they're in So to that end at a minimum
and I do not support the expansion of
this program but as it exist or as it
gets
expanded I believe this bill should be
amended to require
adequate measurement of
outcomes to require an annual compliance
review of the accounts to ensure that
students being enrolled are the students
who are qualified for the program um we
we're not tracking it and we are now
saying if this amendment goes
forward that in year two and then
forward our taxpayer dollars that we
can't find enough of for all the bills
we looked at today for public
education but we're now saying that it
is okay to give these
stipend to wealthy families whose
children will go to those schools
regardless of whether they got the
stipend or
not representative
D are children of wealthy families
entitled to go to public
schools all children are welcomed and
all public schools required to take all
children thank
you okay other yes representative
Brown well representative Damon perhaps
we're reading perhaps we're reading
different reports on success of efas but
first of all it is the state is paying
for efas but to Simply claim it's a
welfare program is absurd um article not
say that I know I'm just I I will get to
my point me so I want to clar I am G I
will respond to your brown has the floor
in a moment um but the comment that this
is just a subsidy and it's a welfare
program is absurd I just want to make
that point
General I know you didn't say that but
it was mentioned that this is just State
paying money and it's it's not really
you know suiting helping students out
um because article 83 says we'll cherish
public education we will not cherish
Public School monopolies and parents
have found that public schools have been
revealed to push Dei CRT curriculum and
and sexually inappropriate material in
their schools and efas Ure that every
child achieves maximum success and
parents have a say in their the schools
their kids go to the progressive policy
Institute reports minority families in
particular are flocking to school choice
programs around the country and
lowincome children have seen quote their
test scores go up with greater gains for
English Learners and students with
disabilities because it makes it easier
for families to choose among a range of
schools second of all the claim that
efas are unaudited is also false there
are three criteria used to track EFA
success in our State national tests
Statewide assessments and
portfolios I've heard a number of people
I've received received emails from
people saying it's un audited that's
false in fact the Nea itself has been
very harsh on drill and kill testing
even labeling standardized testing
discriminatory and racist and preferring
to go with portfolios and Capstone
projects so I can't tell you how pleased
I am today to support this
bill further
comments I have one more comment
representative rcky you you have one no
okay representative lad yeah
um the issue I I'm real concern that the
what bothers me is that when we have the
statement that this program is going to
cost $100 million I think that's totally
uh off off
track if in fact we had Universal for FY
26 and Universal for FY 27 the combined
costs would be a little over $17 million
17.5
million um and and and when I hear this
our taxpayer dollars whose taxpayer
dollars are these the taxpayers dollars
they are my dollars your dollars
everybody's dollars come together to do
this and I feel that everybody who's
paying into our tax system should have
opportunity to gain from that
contribution regardless of whether they
opt for a private school or some other
form of
Education uh so it it's I I have always
been a very strong advocate for public
education and will continue to be that
but I'm also an advocate for those
students which have not been served well
by that particular system and that are
served better in other
opportunities so and and lastly for
those those students now that are going
to be entering as you know up to
400% we we have many of those students
right now 350 are lower but so now we're
going to be getting more students which
are not participating or receiving
benefit from the f&r
program and when you do that then the
amount of differentiated Aid they
receive is less so their average cost is
not going to be $5,200 it's going to be
close to
$4,400 so there there there are a lot of
issues here and and as represent
spillsbury has said
we can get down into the weeds and start
talking about all these dollars and
gains and this and that I I think the
the wisest thing for us to keep in mind
is it what is the best fit for every
child thank you very much so um I don't
want to close off uh debate um but I
would just simply ask that any further
discussion focuses on the specific
purpose of the bill and of the amendment
which has to do with the threshold if
any for means to testing and there will
be a lot of fruitful discussion I think
in the fall on retained bills uh and
going into the second year of the
session on the ongoing questions of
accountability and Audits and Reporting
and so on and I for one fully intend to
engage in those discussions seriously so
are there further comments on the
question of the bill and the amendment
which is the the means testing percent
yes representative luno thanks thanks
very much Mr chair and I appreciate your
comments with regards to the second year
of this session because um we we you
know are expecting a um performance
audit from the state Auditors part of
the legislative uh Bud budget office and
um and uh and I think they'll probably
have a number of recommendations that
that go along the lines of what you
talked about Mr chair but uh but I want
to talk I um I I want to talk about the
um the $17 million
the um estimate cost estimate that
representative lad talked about and the
$102 million um that um that that I
think I've been very transparent on how
I calculated that and while I agree that
maybe not um clearly it's an exposure
level I'm not saying that all 391 fy2
home education students are going to
Avail themselves of a of a voucher but
that um but that uh adding together the
16614 New Hampshire kids that would qu
be eligible for a voucher in a un in the
Universal provision here that attend
private schools plus the um 391 who
attend home education programs uh would
be eligible that you multiply that by
5200 and you get the 102 million but if
we just sort of you know said all right
somehow this this Universal part is
going to be between 17 and a half Mill
17 million what um what what um
represent Vlad said and 102 million that
that you could take a look at what that
would mean for our public schools and
for our our our taxpayers and all we
have to do is go back to the spreadsheet
we got after lunch on House Bill 563 and
I think at one point our our
conversation looked to column n which is
the fiscal capacity disparity Aid which
is currently $13 million total Statewide
even less than what representative lad
is talking about in the low estimate
what I what I would say is the lowball
estimate on um on the uh the the voucher
expansion certainly um it's far less
than 102 million that I think is much
more reasonably justif reasonably
calculated and uh and fully transparent
on how how how I calculate that that
number but if we um if we went with the
uh with the 102 million seriously you
could take all of the the towns all of
the taxpayers that are in these
in these 40 towns that qualify for
fiscal um capacity to disparity Aid and
add another zero on to the end of that
number so so the folks in in Keen um
rather than Keen receiving three um
324,000 it would be 3.2 million would be
their their cont increased contribution
from the state and reduction in local
property taxes um that support their
school and you could go down each one of
these um each one of these places
and uh and see a significant increase
and and it would going back to um to to
all of the things we talked about the
burden on our local taxpayer well here's
$102 million that I think we could we
could use to provide some some property
tax relief and and ease the burden on
our on our property taxpayers and uh
this program I I don't think is the is
certainly not the uh the solution to
that um to that thank you I I think if
there was a consensus that there was a
$100 million exposure then the views of
the committee might be different but
there is no consensus any further
comments yeses thank you Mr chairman um
if I could just
address the the issue seems to be that
we're not talking about a voucher system
we're actually talking about parental
choice and the options that are given so
I want to just testify to my own
personal experience when they cut music
from my district because of the budget
constraints in
1993 we had no choice with our children
we had a single school that was offered
nothing else to do and my children who
needed music were a family of musicians
were not given the option so we pulled
them out and we
homeschooled if I had had this account I
would have still have my wife the
accountant and she would have used this
to send my children to Opportunities and
to places that they could not otherwise
go we could have taken advantage of
conquered School of Music and things
like that without even spending what was
being offered to us because we had a
very frugal we were a single salary a
teacher who was inadequately paid as all
teachers are and my wife who had no
salaries she was The Homeschool mother
so our choice was to do the best we
could with what we could and this would
have increased our ability to do the
best for our kids and when we were done
my children came and joined me because
my colleagues are the best people I've
ever worked with and my children all
went through penber Academy and every
one of them was in honors classes
throughout AP classes throughout and my
son was the drummer for The High School
band when he was in fifth grade thank
you Mr
chair representative papichi Miller
thank you Mr chair I will be brief two
things that I want to make sure are on
the record we did increase education
spending last term by $193 million on a
declining overall enrollment so it's not
like we are not funding public education
if anything it was the biggest increase
that I can think of and second I
appreciate the question of uh what could
we how could we possibly reduce taxes
with another $102 million I I believe
the number was I'd like to just State on
the record that a couple of terms ago we
did exactly that we reduced swept by
$100 million and the impact on property
taxes had has been invisible so we
already know
that taking a hundred million dollar
less from the towns does not lead to a
decrease in property taxes because those
School budgets just inflated immediately
to accommodate for all that and more so
you know facts should be on the record
thank
you okay any new
ground on just to respond to the swept
go ahead question thank you very much Mr
chair so so very interesting the um the
the $100 million cut to swept was done
on a uniform basis to reduce the um the
swept rate that that that would the
equalized rate for all um uh for all
properties uh in New Hampshire except um
except utilities right yeah yeah all
property except all except utilities and
railroads and so so where it very
interesting because in contrast to
fiscal capacity disparity Aid which
talks about
communities which addresses communities
with the least resources where the
biggest tax cuts were because of the100
million swept were in places that are
tremendously resourced because the swept
is such a significant portion of their
property tax so thinking about uh cities
and towns that are fortunate to have a
lake or an ocean in their communities
they saw tremendous tax reduction
when the uh when the swept was cut but
for places that had very high property
taxes like Newport which I think all in
was playing at the time close to $50 per
thousand a um U and I don't remember
what the number was a 75 cent reduction
in their in their state property tax
didn't do much for them but it did a
tremendous amount for places with uh
with low uh lower property taxes so
there's no way you can compare that hund
million swept cut
from
2021 2020 2021 something like that to
what we're talking about with ph I
believe okay thank you um so fair enough
but off
point representative
Ames yeah
uh there clearly division on this issue
and uh different perspectives on the the
value or value of uh of the uh EFA
program or the voucher program depending
on your choice of wording um and the
division is uh is uh hard to
negotiate and there's a great deal of
unknown about uh the consequences of uh
lifting the current cap from 3 50% a lot
of our discussion has focused on
speculation around how that would play
out so I I'm sitting here scratching my
head wondering why the proponents of
this bill are asking us to jump all the
away to throw away the cap not in the
first year that's I guess a compromise
going to 400 but then it's gone which
means that the millionaire or the
billionaire or the uh High salaried
executive who's on his way up or her way
up
um will be able to Bill a part of what
they're paying already for the private
school education of their children um
will be able to build the state for that
part um
it it seems uh
imprudent fiscally irres responsible to
jump like that into a cost
escalation that uh will be out of
control it will either go way up as some
of us think it will I share the views
that have been expressed on that side of
it um or maybe not uh but why not start
at a lower level I'm not asking for that
because I don't think it's a the whole
thing is a good idea but that's that's
uh the way I see this leap that you're
asking the state to take into the
unknown um I'd like to offer a a counter
perspective and uh it's not one that I
think is intended to
persuade uh you or to change your view
but the counterargument is that those
who uh have been the primary proponents
of
efas have reasons many of which are not
quantifiable and never intended for this
particular um uh program to be means
tested and it was means tested when it
was enacted in 2021 as a compromise at
the time to get enactment and uh the
goal is to not have it means tested just
as we do not means test admission to the
public schools so if the state is making
a commitment whatever that figure is
let's say it's an average of 5200 per
student
the the opposite Viewpoint uh again I
don't expect it to persuade but the
opposite Viewpoint is simply that that
fund that amount is following the child
and I think so we've come to a point
where we probably have expressed
everything that needs to be expressed
and there may be in fact two different
philosophical
viewpoints so does anybody else want to
weigh in before we have a vote Yes
Senator Burton thank you very much Mr
chairman I'm just curious given what you
just
said uh being the former financial aid
officer at the
University um for public education and
private
education we means test people to get
financial
aid and so and I I did two or 3,000
applications when I was in that business
some people came in with high incomes
they didn't get the aid because we
wanted to save the aid for the students
who needed
it why why wouldn't we means tests if
that's I'm not a big fan of this all of
my constituents hate it okay so let me
start from there but I respect
everyone's opinion but why don't we mean
test the families who are applying for
efas I said like one of my kids to
private school I admit it because he
wanted to speak Russian I never thought
to ask the state to pay for that that
was my wife's decision my decision and
my kids decision so that's the two why
don't we means test the parents who are
sending their kids for
efas well I it's boot for thought but
you are speaking about the university
level the higher
education thank you representative Mahan
I'd like to take a stop thank you Mr
chairman yeah I'd like to take a stop at
answering your question if I could
because there are a couple of
indiscrepancies that we're not talking
about like the elephant in the room if a
child is mandated to go to a public
school according to idea and he's sent
off to a school that cost
$250,000 a year we don't need test that
child the town pays for that child but
if if we're looking at families and
we're saying we need to need test them
we're not need testing them to put them
into the public school they need the
public school in this case we're
acknowledging that sometimes the public
school doesn't offer What that
particular child needs and therefore
we're offering the parents a choice
that's not the $250,000 private school
that is mandated by the state if it's
specially at IEP involved but we're
giving the family a choice that says do
something else and here's some of your
taxpayer money some of the money you
paid into taxes that you can use for
your own children thank you thank you Mr
chair representative Damon thank you Mr
chair I just want to
acknowledge oh so weird I just want to
acknowledge that in the online testimony
on this bill there are
3,44 people opposed and 791 people
supporting thank you for that
information okay representative
peoples I wasn't going to say anything I
was going to hold back because there's a
lot of conversation going on but um it
occurs to me that the one thing that we
keep talking about and we put them into
like little cubicles or cylinders or
columns or whatever is public schools
charter schools and EFA students they
are all children in the state of New
Hampshire they all should be treated
equally if I floated an email out there
just for response over the weekend with
some of our my colleagues saying why
don't we just throw the whole thing in
the
away and fund every child at
$7,500 they all get $7,500 and they
could spend the money wherever they
wanted for for their
education we're trying to get our
students educated in the best way
fashion that that's good for them uh
providing Choice like this seems to be a
no-brainer to me we we shouldn't be
discriminating against the kids who want
an EFA whether no matter what their
financial situation is just like we
don't on kids that want to go to public
schools I just think that we should
treat all students fairly and not
discriminate against any of
them can I just clarify one point yes
representative Bon earlier I think our
chair and I respect everyone's opinion
mentioned that students who weren't
functioning well in public
schools deserved a place to go when EFA
was away yet I think I hear that 70% of
the students who are got on efas were
already in private schools they weren't
in more than that so I'm not sure how
that unless all the students now going
into efas are coming from PIV Public
Schools maybe they're coming from
private schools that are out of state
maybe your parents are paying for it
they're paying big money for it um I was
just curious about where that came from
the other point I me I used to major in
economics and I remember step functions
you remember step functions from your
economics whereas if we take a so many
children out of a classroom you still
have to run the class so the cost per
credit Goes Up For Students every school
when students are taken out of the
school the cost per credit goes up
unless you eliminate the course and that
takes a course away from the other
students who are in in the public school
building
thank you valid comment and uh what
you're saying is that the cost of
educating a student is not a purely
variable uh expense item uh it comes in
plateaus with fixed costs and capital
asset and teacher classroom size Etc so
fair comment appreciate if you don't
tell me what I said thank you
sir okay um there are clearly divided
views I think the views have had an
opportunity to be
aired and so if there are no further
comments or
questions it's time to call the role on
the amendment yes representative
Bicky
I I just am having a hard
time dealing with the fact
that we're talking about not
discriminating
today yet last
week when we were looking at feeding all
children we talked about discrimin we we
that whole thing about discrimination
never came up I am
disgusted thank
you all right the clerk will call the
role on Amendment
0651 H to
hb15 Chairman spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
dry yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Burton no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no Representative bricky no
Representative crian no representative
Weinstein no chairman lad yes 10 8
n okay the vote on the amendment being
104 and8 against um I will look to
representative lad for a final motion
thank you very much Mr chairman I'd like
to recommend otpa using Amendment 0651 H
for
hb15 got to get a second okay second on
the uh motion second second by
representative Earth thank you I have no
further discussion no further discussion
any other comments I'm sure there'll be
further discussion but not right now I
think that's that will be welcome in an
appropriate time thank
you okay see no further discussion the
rep clerk can call the
rooll chairman spillsbury yes
representative Maguire yes
representative
yes representative dry yes
representative kcom yes representative
pich yes representative Brown yes
representative mahagan yes
representative peoples yes
Representative luno no representative
Ames no representative Britain no
representative fellows no representative
Damon no Representative bricky no
representative Jen no representative
Weinstein no chairman lad yes ten 8
n okay so the motion carries otpa 10 to8
and uh representative lad you'll write
the majority report and who would like
to write The Minority
Report yeah no I'll be doing them
representative
Luna thank you okay that ends the
executive session on hp15 thank you very
much repres representative spillsbury uh
before we leave I want to let everybody
know that we will be meeting next on
February the
12th February excuse
me long day guys uh March March the 12th
uh most likely at 10:00 I think that's
the time we put down uh we will be
addressing the remaining bills which
have to be out of committee by March the
20th and so we will be EXE
those those remaining bills that I I
think you're all familiar with I don't
have them in front of me right here but
so just know on
3 12 we will be meeting and these bills
are
237 354 443
461 549 656 and 729 they I believe
that's all been sent out to you earlier
we had a original date of the the 11th
voting day or election date and that was
canceled but the same bills have just
been carried forward to the next
Wednesday so the following week we have
to have those reports out
so that's what we have on the dock in
front of us and I will be uh developing
some subcommittees here and I'll get
together with everybody uh uh when we
meet next for you know imparting the
names to folks right here represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman so for the
purpose of my scheduling finance
division one do you is it a portion of
March 12th that will be here or yeah
when well see on the Thursday we have a
session day and
then I can't so so is it just morning is
you're meeting in the morning I'm asking
I'm asking what how much of the day do
you think this committee will need on
March 12th
like to do
it well we can't do it on well you don't
want to do it on the 11th do you you
need well we need to get it done no so
is the 11th an
option the yes the 11th is an option for
some committees that have had that
approved I'm not enthralled by it I can
ask for that approval for division one I
mean yeah I know it I know that the
finance has already gone that route we
could do it on the
11th but we're it's being frowned on
doing that so because we have other
people want to attend from other
committees and from the house public
I'll schedule finance division one on
the 11th thank you no that's that's we
know how Finance works so I mean I have
town meeting on yeah we're not going to
do it on the 11th so it's the 12th we
have it scheduled the other item I don't
have my calendar in front of me we of
course we always do it on the Friday
um following
session let me
look and I would prefer to hear what
representative Damon said let's do it on
the
Wednesday um if we did that we could try
to coordinate with people in
finance if they're doing it all day long
I think we're wiser just staying with
the 12 and call and yeah we we we're
going to have it on the 12th and we'll
just call people down when we get to the
point where we're voting or we could
even get where you're obligated to be in
another place too we could get subs if
you're on Dual committees and doing at
the same time so we'll work that
out
so yeah we're setting it up we're not
changing from the 12
yeah oh yeah there there's a room
available we would be going probably
down the hallway here yeah there there's
a room available I already checked out
so we're good so I guess that takes care
of today's work and and thank you very
much and have a safe drive home blurs do
tomorrow morning yeah 10:00 please is
the at the latest y